up we don't want to launch a cross save
and then all of a sudden turn it off
immediately and then have to turn it off
and then some poor tenno's account is
lost in eternalism of the version of
them that didn't get you know rescued
rescued so we have to
hey
you know that scene and then these
references
but anyway so we're starting with parody
event uh and then we have also i think
there's also like relay destruction
things that have to get synchronized as
well so bringing the databases kind of
to heal and then off we go okay great
yeah there's a list and we're going to
get it all done yep that's how we go
that's cool there you go that's the
update well before it's canceled if you
believe me who are you going to believe
i don't know choose one of us is right
okay
well
we'll see but anyway uh we are going to
now give stuff away kind of oh as we do
yeah
we're launching a giveaway you have to
enter this but would you like to see it
yeah dean play that oh is this the
computer yeah
yeah yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how does that even
oh yeah
this is the first time sheldon's seen
this i've never seen that thing
we need a banana for scale so when you
plug your rooms
that's a four foot tall computer it's
made by pc modder ak mod they have built
this one of a kind custom looked
amazing ceremony 10-0 tower it's
incredible um this is actually a gleam
giveaway and it's going to be live until
august 16th so if you're in twitch. you
can just do exclamation point giveaway
and it'll get you a nice little link so
you can
you can't win it if you work at digital
extremes i'm sorry i cannot win it i'm
sorry but you put an order in for one
activation point giveaway
get all the information on it uh again
august 16th you have until then so get
yourself a chance at a four foot tall
serum and ten zero pieces one-of-a-kind
towers it's insane
honestly amazing work uh putting that
hole beautiful computer and giveaway
campaign together good job team that is
nice
best computer i've ever seen and we'll
never have i know it's like out of reach
it hurts we give but we hurt and this is
the internalism where we don't get it
we don't know we could wow
jokes we had a lot happen today we did
and at 4 pm something really exciting
happened we deployed a update on all
platforms today uh if you haven't got it
yet you can download the update get in
the duvery amphitheater it's on earth
but yes the update went live on all
platforms today and we launched core
prime she's out she's here whoa farm
access we've debuted on the art panel
little tease you were there was i yeah
did you spoil it again
eternalism jeff spoiled it again for
sure trouble but uh
maybe we should show the prime trailer
oh we have a prime trailer sure do you
sure do dean rollins
[Music]
none of them truly understands how much
i lost
when i lost her
[Music]
nor by what subtle art my dead love now
lives
within another's gleaming skull
so tonight
we shall celebrate
in her honor and mine
i shall unveil a new creation
a harmony
of mistress
and monster
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
an apex predator
a deathless companion
unsurpassed
blood raw in whip
claw
and fang
cora
all right so that is the core prime
access trailer again launched today did
you know we should also launch
what else should we launch a giveaway oh
we do the first card
the first one you're the closest
you're also the only one with laser eyes
that's why the winner you have to go get
a snack go now while sheldon tries to
read the giveaway we're going to give
away a core prime access to one lucky
twitch viewer let's go let's go
the answer is oh it's scrolling by
oh it's
[ __ ] phase jump bass jump
of the year congrats she launched today
that prime access is all yours live
messages
i think we have key art we can show in
case you want a closer look at her and
all her beauty the team did a fantastic
job with cora and her
venari prime that's cool it's got the
hysterics prime the dual carries prime
alternate prime helmet which is really
awesome just
all hot so beautiful oh man i love that
trailer i love just love this design and
just
listening to ballast scott scott was
saying he could listen to him just like
reading bedtime stories yeah
i'm sure you're not alone in the
community
for that he needs like a redemption arc
maybe like new war kind of
don't spoil him he's not so
okay never mind yeah
some people haven't played the new war
but you should but yeah that's okay
maybe maybe that was like his bro
there's always room for maybe maybe
maybe he's got like a twin brother
way more lovable
we were separated at birth
you know
like a light switch like an elementary
school teacher yeah
but we also launched today if you're a
fan of actually oh if you're watching
and you have your account linked you can
get titania prime for free yeah 30
minutes make sure you're linked up oh
good we also launched a titania skin
today the donut skin which is a deluxe
skin everything's there which also
showed an art show but you don't
remember that i don't know he does it
was like a month ago don't trust him but
um
don't trust it don't trust him it's all
in memory yes oh there it is look at the
key art that was amazing
oh man i do love that so much got the
lux razor wings and everything dex
pictures so all you have to do is watch
this and you get them no no no no no no
no no no no no please no
i thought you could contain your prime
he just loves this
[Laughter]
listen
he's just clapping yes
never mind never mind we're good sorry
all right can i help myself yeah so
that's all live in the update today
that's alive and going live tomorrow we
did announce uh pre-announced at this
but nightwave north choice volume two is
going live tomorrow at the classic
weekly reset time for us it's 8 p.m
eastern time but we have a
new night wave she's gonna have some new
cosmetics bring back some old ones as
well and if you're unfamiliar with what
night wave is basically like a kind of
seasons pass we used to have an alert
system but we took that out and now we
do night waves so it's voiced by nora
knight which is uh super fun and it's
just a nice little free path for some
cosmetics she's got her own store and
you do acts uh every week yep completely
free just a way to earn stuff while
playing the game launching tomorrow
night wave my wave baby
fantastic yeah
all right
we usually start a little bit more on
our tenno lives with a little bit of a
recap and there's one thing from the
panels today that we wanted to bring
over
oh oh oh the from the art panel oh no
spoilers i do what did you do they
always they always attack you like
where's the skin that you showed i was
actually genuinely surprised at the our
panel how much
we were allowed to show on their panel
oh wow so someone gave you permission to
show it well
or ask forgiveness
that's how we work around here that's
how we work yes but we were you know
we've been working on warframe for quite
some time we're always looking for new
ideas for our next warframes and we got
the opportunity to work with industry
legend from comics to video games joe
mad and joe madd had been working on a
wolf inspired warframe iterating on it
and bringing all these ideas to the
table and we ended up with a concept
that we're going to be using for a
future warframe of our wolf inspired
warframe let's take a look at what um
joe madd worked on we had eric vetter
here working from de's side and
you know it's uh a thing of beauty she
will be
having
quite the uh the power set and you can
look forward to hearing more about that
uh in your future dev streams just
howlingly good
howling good
monsters guys they're cool monsters
but there's no uh you know there's some
it's not a coincidence that we were you
know lucky enough to work with joe madd
on on yeah i mean we're everyone here at
d were huge fans of joe madd he's just
you know he like you were saying and all
the games that him and his team work on
here
the team there's another 90s kid though
90s comics and stuff yeah come on
totally you can't you can't not and and
the team that they have at airship
syndicate is a fantastic one
and we're excited to kind of talk about
the next steps that de is taking in
partnership with airship syndicate maybe
we should roll it let's take a look
hey
don't swivel steve you're already
squibbling i know
drop some hot bars joe i can talk louder
i'm the loudest talker
[Laughter]
do you have enough tape for all this
they don't have tapes anymore steve it's
the future
and i feel like we had a great banter we
did have great banter yeah
yeah
hey everyone this is joe mad from
airship syndicate hope you guys are
enjoying tennocon unfortunately we
couldn't be there this year i did have
the honor of designing a brand new
warframe hope you had a chance to check
it out a lot of people have asked what
we're working on next and we haven't
been able to talk about it something
we're really excited about it's our best
game yet hey i'm steve matara one of the
lead designers at airship syndicate i'm
ryan stephanelli i'm the president and
game director here at airship and we're
really excited to be partnering with
digital extremes on our next big thing
it's a third person action game new
original characters original world never
been seen before we never would have
tried this type of game right away
that's why we started with something
like battle chasers then we dabbled in
multiplayer with darksiders genesis and
now we're we're going all in with this
new game this is our biggest game yet
we're building a much larger world than
we ever have before but for this it's
really more of a world that you live in
potentially every day for years to come
we've been fans of many genres over the
years and we've sort of worn those
influences on our sleeve one genre we
never really thought that we could touch
on is mmos
for us like we played a lot of games
together online so it's fun for us to
finally get to work on a game like this
where we're building a world that
players can experience together i don't
think we would have tackled this type of
online game without a partner like de a
group that knows how to do it i was
actually one of the people who bought
into the initial founder's pack i still
have my excalibur prime you know
warframe is touted as one of the most
successful
games of its kind it's always evolving
and introducing exciting stuff and we
definitely do not want to blunder
through something like that
this game is really character focused
the characters have personalities they
have relationships with each other we
want players to feel excited about all
of the different characters that they're
going to have in their arsenal we're
mixing in a lot of modern sensibilities
and modern technology into
those fantasy definitions to create
something brand new what makes this game
special is the sense of adventure and
camaraderie the secret locations it's
got an identity people are going to be
so jazzed this project represents really
being able to like go big to everyone
that has supported us since the
beginning i can honestly say this game
is for you guys
we didn't get to say a lot of details
and specifics about the game but we'd
love for everyone to talk to us on
discord get involved in our social
channels and get ready for this
december's tga's where
it'll all be revealed
[Applause]
[Music]
indeed indeed you can check out the game
awards later this year to see what
exactly the game is but and they're
going to have the shik robot back it's
going to be amazing
[Laughter]
well that's all right
i can't believe he's got
like a founder pack and he's got so
excited
that's true that is what did you say
about the partnership
oh yeah i don't remember well this is it
this is it those things what did you
call it i don't know i think you just
called it a partnership i think i just
said partner no no there's more it was a
tm it was a tv okay
a partnering
would i make it an active verb
workshop
if we
could see chat they would tell us yeah
chat would definitely be telling us we
don't have a chat feed we just have we
just have uh us time to talk warframe oh
okay
oh warframe remember that yes we have
been working hard on you know getting
everyone ready to see a taste of the
duvery paradox you're probably seeing
some key elements on stage but what if
we told you we were working on another
update as well oh something for the
post-new war
side of warframe i think all of us you
know came out of the new war released in
december it's been just over seven
months veso dating sim
please
no spoilers
no spoilers oh
but uh we we really want to take what we
did with the new war and all the amazing
content in it and bring it to you tenno
in a new update let's take a look at
what's coming
[Music]
soon um
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
call
not
afraid
[Music]
veil breaker
is an update to that
breaker
yeah it's a pretty good name you like it
yeah
yep we're going to give that one to you
breaking veils
breaking veils but bail breaker is an
update that's dedicated to the state of
the origin system that you know after
the new war so if you play the new war a
lot of things are really going to stand
out from that trailer um and if you
haven't you'll be introducing yourself
to a lot of those characters soon we
hope you know maybe you want to try out
the new one and this is really going to
take the state of the origin system and
the conflict and everything i don't want
to say too much because i don't want to
spoil it for people that didn't play the
new war but a lot of what of that video
showcased hopefully you can really infer
where we're going with it and um there's
going to be
a ton to talk about and we are hoping
that the veil breaker update is going to
come out before the duvery paradox we'll
keep you posted on development updates
devstreams but we're hoping you can get
your hands on it this year so
we'll have devstreams to talk about it
but we wanted to introduce you tenno to
veilbreaker as an update uh show you a
trailer of what you can definitely
expect in it
but one thing absent from that trailer
that's a very important part of the veil
breaker update
is the fact that we are going to be
releasing our 50th unique
five
warframe
five zero baby oh man
i know it need a moment
i remember when we were pitching this
game scott will remember this we were
pitching this game uh when we didn't
think we could do it independently way
back in uh
is that ten years ago now
ten years ago and i think how many
warframes do we have eight at the time
and they said i don't even think we had
eight i don't think we had maybe like
four or six four that were really solid
and six that were and a prominent
executive asked well like are you
worried you're gonna run out of ideas
for warframe just because you already
got it
now now we have 50. exciting we're at 50
i'm just checking on our servers as you
know we do an ambitious live event
everything oh how's everything going on
we're just taking a look sit down
sit tight everyone um we won't uh if
you're having connectivity issues don't
worry team is on it sit tight we'll get
you up so things are heating up in the
hampshire cleaning up okay the hamstring
wheels i can hear i can hear them i
should have changed their wood chips you
know and it's just they're not going to
run as fast yeah okay without the fresh
chips
so on the 50th warframe topic uh we're
going to be debuting fully in a uh well
why don't we give you a little tease of
how you're going to learn about the 50th
warframe
will be making his reveal in an animated
short that we will be uploading closer
to the laundromat
no it's like a it's like a six minute
little short film yeah partnered with uh
passion paris i believe yeah um but we
will be showing that uh very you know
closer to the veil breaker
information bits and everything but that
is styanax he is our 50th unique
warframe and you can learn all about him
and his that looks so sick honestly it's
honestly really great gorgeous yeah yeah
can you believe and it's going to give
me like from then until when it releases
from now until it releases i'm going to
be practicing how to say the name of
x yeah i'm going to be practicing his
origin is of that of the
noble greek warriors
style
relax
yeah okay
you got it yeah nailed it
no it is easy to say i'm going to be in
the group
for those of you doing bullet points for
your viewers or for your videos
failbreaker coming soon
steinax the 50th warframe and a lot more
or not might have spotted protea deluxe
in that trailer
very true
yeah
you're just making up words
now megan i noticed you have some stuff
on your lap you know i just thought i'd
sit here
these segways are getting so
sophisticated
[Laughter]
no
i love it no i would like to give it
away i don't want to be holding it
anymore i want you to be holding it uh
we have a couple giveaways from close to
your ipad with your next
we were lucky enough to be sponsored by
hp omen to give away some stuff with a
full laptop okay oh look at that
he's got assets don't worry it's coming
up this is um
hp omen they have been giving us some
sweet one-of-a-kind things to give away
uh first bundle we're gonna give away
live twitch picker is going to be the
headset and the keyboard with the custom
keycaps i like that we have assets but
you made megan hold it yeah did i make
you i made myself that's what i thought
i requested that the items be here so
that i could hold it this is my own
anyways custom pc and also the custom
headset so it's running right now
here we go right here the winner oh my
god
that's actually my account
all right that account please whisper
warframe to a channel with your in-game
alias and your shipping information so
we can send you this keyboard did you
request this caller
no but aren't we so excited about it you
totally
you can't have it but you can have it
we're also now giving away this laptop
another pair of headsets uh via the
twitch picker so dean roll it let's see
if it's a more complicated one for
sheldon okay let's see if we can trip
him up
oh bit of feedback
[Music]
this one is her esther palace puff
congrats uh
great life hacking zoomed in with my
phone her's derp palace
dirt palace no wait oh my god it's
working is it working
all right apple lips are you zooming in
with your camera yes
our custom laptop giveaway with headset
this is yours you need to message our
twitch chat in whispering send it to us
as a direct message on twitch your
shipping address so we can or broadcast
it to everybody no don't do not do that
thank you to old man for uh sending this
over and creating these i can't wait for
those two winners i got them it's
amazing this off my lap yeah yeah and
maybe we should also do power play oh
wouldn't you like a hundred thousand
platinum hmm wouldn't you i sure would
have a thousand a hundred that would be
nice
i don't know how we green like these
ones but anyways
ask for forgiveness not permission
that's how i work all right all right
all right 100 000.
wow
that's the quad underscore that was
quick uh you've won
guys they just went 100 000 platinum
holy crap that's a lot good job how are
we holding up
should we kick off the theater or uh
glenn says we were recovered oh good the
the the swamping the swamping my web
situation real quick okay i have to make
sure to make sure that i'm in place
would you want me to take all the
belongings i'll take a laptop no let's
give it to you
oh man all right story winners you've
never gotten these yeah sheldon's let me
do a list so so far um you have got to
see the bail breaker update reveal
you've got to see a lot of you know
things that are in live build for you
and a teaser steinax jesus amazing and
we are now going to go into the world
reveal live gameplay demo of the duvet
paradox
oh this is world record it's literally
time okay
so i have to go over to the demo pc so
i'm just going to draw my notes here uh
anything you want to say i thought we
were going to stall more or something
yeah just having like a chat this feels
sudden to me there is time
we're uh we're ready to rock oh my gosh
are you guys ready is everyone is
everyone ready for this
no
as i walk over the stage ceremoniously
just so you know anything to say i just
i want to say like this isn't a volume
this is not ilm like this is real
just like like
like it's real you know
this is not like a obi-wan show no
it's physical
sorry
all right okay we're gonna sit quiet
okay you guys ready well what's there to
say
is there no like um
camera for you on no no no oh yeah all
right all right let's get started just a
voice
a voice from the void if you aren't in
game go to the diviri amphitheater on
earth megan's there now and we're going
to start the show yeah this is going to
be a really cool kind of interleaved
show look how cool this is yeah awesome
oh that's the okay so people are there
so things are working things are working
yeah
it's just
as we wait for the daviri paradox
there's something everyone should know
about it
which is that it's going to come earlier
in the game than you'd expect
the davier paradox is indeed a paradox
and to that end
you may
find yourself wondering if you are
required to play the new war to play the
daviri paradox and the answer is no no
it'll be earlier in the warframe journey
and we're going to be taking it in lots
of strange and weird directions to that
end
because
what is a paradox if not
an anomaly in time in space
and for us
taking all those themes and pushing them
into this update has been a lot of fun
and frankly
quite exciting for
the future of warframe
yeah i can't wait to see it the daviri
amphitheater is live on all platforms
and our
gracious host bomberstein
will invite you
to participate
in the davier paradox amphitheater
experience
get in there it doesn't start soon i'm
just gonna
wait
we're
we're letting everyone get in everyone
needs to be able to see this the we can
see the the numbers rising we have a
little ticker over on the side every
relay keeps filling up thanks guys for
coming in
but we're going to give them a few more
minutes we don't want to start the demo
without
everybody in place so
bear with us
all right
oh 100 more 200 more scott
scott's not even watching the ticker
he's got stairs can't watch anymore
can't watch the ticker can't watch it
all right i'll just go ahead with the
demo all right all right we're going to
start
get ready
oh hold on some megan's getting it's
making its way through the demo is about
to begin
packets are
ever get that feeling you're stuck
spinning inside your little wheel day in
and day out
only defined
be right back where you started
and so it goes
day by day
year by year
spinning and spinning
until you're dead
or in my case
until you're dead inside
never asking
what am i doing this for
whose dream am i living
[Music]
you are hereby consigned and sentenced
to death by royal order of his majesty
dominus thrax
hero of all
[Music]
get on with it
death by
impalement
how curious
that doesn't
[Music]
[Music]
back in your place
and the daring night was slain
or maybe not
[Music]
hello
what
[Music]
a glimmer
until the greatest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
what's gotten into you
my world
my rules
[Music]
spot
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's the king
[Music]
[Applause]
this is the intro quest to the diviri
paradox
so what you're seeing right now is
the onboarding experience
for the quest
where where
he gave me no eyes to see him
there i think it's him
sir will the dragon devour us today i
live to serve even as fool what
that attack
didn't you hear it
someone can tell me how our theater
event's going
all right
no worries
this is an open world experience but he
does a lot of twists
the world does not look
vibrant it looks rather
colorless
our drifter is living the same day
but something has changed
[Music]
this place can change
this place can change
[Music]
let's follow and see where we go
um
[Music]
[Music]
the king
graces us
i
am bombastine
zion
you do remember your courtly playwright
hey hey i am not have you come to join
the performance sire
it would be
my deepest honor to see you command the
stage
yonder you might recover your favorite
mask
my favorite mask
yes manifest as only you are able
with untold power as only you command
quicksile i can only stall this awful
idiots gallery for a while longer
evidently we have to go find
a match
perhaps we can get some assistance
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
how do i know this
[Music]
oh
[Music]
at least you're not trying to kill me
[Music]
what
the
hell
there we go
[Music]
back we go
the king
returns
and in such a mood as this he wears
what recitation will you gift us today
i'm not
uh
[ __ ]
line feed of course sire which
play
now here we find ourselves with a very
important decision
as you play through the open world
diviri paradox experience you're going
to be given opportunities to choose
your attributes your build for that
particular day that play session in this
case players of veteran players of
warframe even new ones will recognize
heat damage as a you know a way to get
your melee built up
in this case we have the option to
instantly summon and mount a loyal cave
which happens to be that skeletal force
i'm riding and then king's rebuke which
is a decree that allows you to have a
burst when you
dodge
i'm going to go with loyal steed just to
show this off
during tennocon here today uh this is
going to be something that you'll have
so you don't need to choose from it
normally but um we're just going to use
it today for the demo
when i destroyed i bestride him i i soar
is more musical
the pipe of hermes
riveting
i was on the edge of my seat
moving
well done sire
they
love you
right
diviri is a strange place it is a place
where your choices will allow you to
build
builds for your drifter and what's to
come
and let's take a look at using that
decree right now
instant horse
but where to next
okay
the very paradox open world is a strange
place
and it seems as though there's another
one of these statues here
let's take a look at that
and light it up
[Music]
i thought i had lost you for a moment
but you don't get to leave
ah so now i've chosen my respawn point
and i can escape the dragon
the oral worm loaded
[Music]
safety in the caves tenno
[Music]
all right
[Music]
the cave of daviri
a memory clad in a steel dream
swifter than both shots more loyal than
a steadfast soldier's heart
run true noble cave
[Music]
we are in a very strange place folks
now of course
this is a warframe update
but this is also
the introductory quest to the duvery
paradox
so we will see where this goes
[Music]
[Music]
so
you
finally took the hand
did you
what finally
today's the first fool
you know how this works
why would today be the first time
your ignorance is second only to your
apathy
what i struggle
to comprehend
is why the other side is even trying to
help you
the other side
who's trying to help me
uh you are
see
for yourself
you should make a choice here i think
see where it goes
gotta stay true to the poster boy
[Music]
i
thought so
old dogs and new tricks go on go wallow
in your routine
fine i'm getting out of here on my own
oh
now
that would be a surprise wouldn't it
take my old blades if you want a chance
with that mockery of a dax
perhaps we're simply not ready yet
to take on a warframe
i see until next time
we're unveiled in scars and sorrows
i cannot tell you how long he has
dwelled with us
i only know that something has compelled
him
to watch and wait
us
oh
oh
[Music]
and is weeks
[Music]
[Music]
got him
ten ten
[Music]
but
i'm afraid there's only one way to take
down an airborne beast
i hope i have the
tools to do so
here we go
me
[Music]
oh
[Music]
how dare he keep trying to leave
what's out there that's so fascinating
[Music]
maybe i
should just go there
myself
and that is
no
all right we're caught in the paradox
i'm so easily excitable but that's so
awesome the open world experience coming
with the duvet paradox is going to be
everything you love about warframe your
builds and everything you know is going
to come to you through this drifter's
point of view the experience where you
start off as the underdog and as you
play through your decrees will be bound
to you for that play session and we're
really trying to play with very
different things for this open world
experience narrative uh you know those
three frames in the cave yeah or maybe
just a little a sick call back yeah yeah
i love that or call forward because the
paradox
i can't even make sense of it all
eternalism has messed me up
so yeah and you got to see a little bit
of the amphitheater uh dubiouri
amphitheater experience we had a live
show there if you're probably in a relay
still right now you're still in there
the dragon's probably roaring around
because vomisteen does have a farewell
for you uh in a bit but you can hang out
hang out with the dragon and walk around
i mean this is an old tobey maguire
reference but i was thinking an alt
title would be unpleasantville
okay you know okay
no no that's not landing for anyone eh
okay
[Laughter]
that was unbelievable i just love the
color the dragon and the flying around
the dragon
stunning there is stunning there's
things happening cooking and that old
guy who's that old guy
with those swords i feel like i
recognize his voice i recognize
[Laughter]
a little bit of shakespeare i mean it's
got everything you need
hopefully you enjoyed the gameplay
reveal of the davier paradox that was
the quest or part of the quest for you
to start off your journey and we're
going to be working very hard this year
very very hard on it
yes
and we had one of the relay events
worked no i think they too we had tessen
and oh yes we had two of them were the
horse yes
they were i think people were able to
experience uh some of it my pc was
having a bit of a struggle so you know
what maybe we'll play that experience
again at a later date
if there were any issues we will run it
again yes
our it team is working right now
feverishly to try to even get those last
two workings i'm sure i appreciate their
work
uh and i appreciate of course everyone's
interest and cramming in there and
wanting to watch it with us and yeah oh
yeah beautiful
great job
i just love the way the color works and
just that thing in the sky the cloud
oh god at the end yeah there's going to
be a lot with this update you may have
noticed the world changed a lot when we
came in and out and moods are a huge
part of what will make each day feel
different so
when he met
when he's mad he's mad yeah watch it
awesome
okay so is that it
kind of
kind of not i don't know well yeah i
guess uh
yeah i probably was supposed to be
prepared to have like a more structured
speech but uh you know it's why start
now we've already
structured now
uh but yeah this is i guess
we wanted to share with our community
some news about the growth of d.e
amazing and the growth of the team and
um i guess
i can probably just do it with symbolism
you know
and just kind of do this right yes
symbolism and just you know if you've
been with us for a while what color are
those are those faded are they
they've been washed a few times
oh my gosh uh and uh i think it's time
that uh
warframe has a new leader and uh and
it's gonna be you
and i'll put these on
oh
i mean they are clean i said no no no no
no yes
today but yeah i think it's you know we
started this game uh
more than 10 years ago and uh we it's a
big important part of our lives and yeah
and
and we made it in a way that that we
hadn't made games before which was with
all of you at home
uh supporting us
funding us when we didn't have uh a
publisher and we were kind of striking
out on our own and
and uh
this is something that we are going to
try again
uh and as
you know
the younger generation uh is going to
take over warframe and and
and phase in
that year
the old buggers
my beard has maybe maybe just a little
bit of pepper left in the salt uh
the old buggers are going to try to do
it again with you at home
and
i think that's probably all there is to
say about it for now we have prepared
for you a taste of that experience that
we want you to join us with
its creation so thank you very much for
that amazing very demo
and
yeah it's time to see the next story
that we're adding to the studios you
know
legacy going forward i hope yeah i hope
you like it
[Music]
it began a song
pitched sweet and solemn
[Music]
they that held
came hollow
fallen
the children raised in castles loved
made hunters
grave
of others
not
remember this
we
are a family
[Music]
yet young the pale of odin's sky
live verdant fields of rain and wild
[Music]
where roman beasts of alkas lost
[Music]
remember stilt
until the ghost
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
so listen well
and of shame
[Music]
and bear their souls within your frame
[Music]
find your spirit
your grace renewed
[Music]
and returned to earth
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
join us
won't you
[Music]
huh
[Music]
let's do this
[Music]
ready
let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
you